hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it's a game
two of the finals of the feeder Grand
Prix I only promise you with the white
pieces against wayy way he has to win on
the man because he lost the previous
game and he lost when Apple had the
black pieces so this is an immense task
for for wiiii to accomplish if he is to
get back into the game and take this
match in two tiebreaks away is now MBL's
only chance to get into the candidates
tournament in in 2020 so let's see what
what we prepared and we also have a nice
photo of the matchup compliments of
Nikki Riga official photographer of the
feeder Grand Prix there we have it both
players ready ready to battle it out you
can see both players brought brought
water to the game but nipple also
brought is a thermos bottle probably
coffee or tea to keep him alert at all
stages of the game he's expecting this
to be a wild game since we has to win on
demand with the black pieces and also if
you know the name of the gentleman
making the first move for nipple do
share in the comments so we can all
enjoy you know and expand our own vast
knowledge and as you can see the
gentlemen made d4 under move but nipple
does not like d4 he prepared efore for
this game so he you know retracted the
move in there made another move which is
e for and already from one we have
exciting stuff on the board away he goes
for g6 the modern defense we have d4
Bishop g7 Knight to c3 nipple just
continues normal development we have d6
Knight to f3 and now a six so this is a
system a lot of players to use when they
have to win undermanned against a really
strong player because it's flexible you
don't have anything but then again now
white doesn't know everything by heart
but on this level who knows maybe nipple
even does now but okay Bishop d2 neppo
continues normal development we have
East six and castles we have Knights the
e7 and rook to e1 by Napa and here there
is one game where castles was played but
Knight to d7 it's a new move so it is as
of move 7 that we have a completely new
game Nico
a nipple plays a 4 prevents expansion by
black under now on the Queen side maybe
maybe has a 5 plant we have b6
preventing that now if a5 now you know
you can go b5
we have Bishop to e3 and now Bishop to
b7 just also continuing development you
can see it's a very flexible opening
both bishops fianchettoed knights and e7
and e 7 so you can pretty much play this
any way you want
Queen to d2 with an idea of training of
the dark-squared bishop at some point
also connecting rooks with h6 and now
comes h3 just waiting to see what what
we will do we have g5 an epaulette have
to really do anything he just has to
play solid moves and he's in the
candidates tournament with g5 starting
the expansion on the Kings side and now
that d5 which is a very principled
decision when your opponent comes at you
on the Kings side you want to reply with
a response in the center so the five we
have E 5 way he wants to keep the
central closed if he is to attack on the
Kings side we have Knight to H 2 now
with ideas
well denied will now come to f1 to g3
maybe to f5 would be an excellent square
for the knight we have Knights the g6 we
use Knight wants to come to f4 we have
Bishop to g4 planning to bring it all
the way to f5 we have Knight to f6 now
attacking the bishop and knights the f1
now not really buttered with a nightcap
person g4 h captures pretty much stops
any ideas you could have on the King
side so Knights the f4 now the H v
square is defended you are preparing to
push it will rush up to f5 so h5 doesn't
come with tempo and h5 with g3 attacking
the knight and now comes Bishop to h6
here you don't really you don't really
win a piece if you capture the night
because if captures captures then the
bishop here is trapped you don't have a
square for it so it's not really doing
anything for white except giving black
the open G file for attack
so after this Bishop to h6 nipple goes
f3 now this is a threat because you've
free DF 2 square for Bishop but we says
I'm going all out here rook the g8 so
Nippo
still doesn't go for characters he
doesn't want it's still not a piece
because now characters captures it comes
with check so first King to h1 by nipple
and now worship
see a thing okay still capture capture
the night I need my open G file to
create some chances and here neppo does
capture the Night Live G captures an F
for G captures an F for and Bishop to f2
and now yet another sacrifice by way E
and Knight captures on e4 and here of
course nepo accepts it with F captors on
e4 if you capture with the bishop then
black can grab the h3 pawn not something
you want to allow so e captures F
captures on e4 and now Queen to g5 okay
so we definitely made some progress here
he's threatening Queen G to mate it's
your move what do you play here feel
free to pause the video and find the D
best move for nipple while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
a beautiful defensive resource and for
those of you who just want to enjoy a
show it's the shop character son b6 you
already grabbed two pieces you don't
need another one but you do need to
prevent mate so after this is captured
now you go nice to h2 and then now
blacks attack is over this night is
coming to f3 the rook is coming to g1
and there is no and there is no good
move for black here it's well black of
course we'll still play this since he
cannot adjust the resign but you know
you can't even afford a slow move like
Bishop characters simply robed you want
and it's over Queen moves you will have
to give up the rook there's there's no
way to play this but nepo did not play
this nip Oh it only needs a draw to get
into the candidates tournament so he
plays Knight to III he gives up a piece
this way Knight now guards the G 2
square we captures it F captures now
again this is a threat of mate so now
Bishop captures an e3 now the Queen
guards the G to square also not the
route can come to g1 we have Queen to g3
by way e giving up yet another piece and
here
Napo has to capture it otherwise he's
just gonna be worse so here Neto
captured the bishop with Bishop captures
on h6 but now we have Queen f3 check
King h2 and Queen to g3 with check and
it was in this position on move 26 that
yani pony and the way
agreed to a draw since there is nothing
more to be done here if black doesn't
continue checking the White King he's
just gonna be worse and if well that's
basically just it you're gonna have a
repetition here our king h1 Queen f3
check and the dis is going to be a nice
repetition so that's the game we draw
draws the second game with the black
pieces and that means maple closes up
the match in the classical time section
so he doesn't take it even into the
rapids which is something they Poe very
very often does and young poem she wins
the Fida grand prix and wins a spot in
the candidates tournament 2020 which
means Oh yet another candidates
tournament will be played without a
maxime beaugeois graph that's a that's
you know very sad but you know the rules
are rules and it is the way it is it's
it's always like like last time he he
almost got it almost got it to be at the
rating almost got it via the Philly
Grand Prix but he just he just can't get
it get into the candidates tournament
which is insane I mean a tough break for
him because I mean it's it's the only
way to become world champion now he's
gonna have to wait for for the second
cycle and that's definitely not fun but
yeah I'm interested what do you think
about the way Yi's decision to go all
out in a game like this or maybe you
think he should have gone with a slow
approach and not lashing out and see
maybe maybe you know in fifth hour of
the of play maybe nipple will make a
mistake and then maybe he can get back
into this match or then maybe it just
doesn't mean all that much for ways
since we doesn't have a chance to win
you know a spot in the candidates and
he's happy with with second place but
yeah they are playing black against
nipple not really something you can you
can push so a draw is more than okay
here and a lot of you have been asking
me who is in the candidates tournament
now well I prepared it and well there
are unbelievably the the Wikipedia page
for the 2020 candidates tournament is
really updated as you can see the wild
card is already set to be Kirilenko and
I checked this as soon as this game
Napo verses that we finished and they
updated it immediately since you know I
was very impressed by that so you have
Fabiana Caruana of course he's the 2018
World Championship runner-up Magnus
Carlsen won so Fabiano gets into the
interior candidates tournament and in
the next cycle you have the top two
finishers finishers at the 2019 World
Chess Club which is team order a job of
who won the tournament ending Liron who
won second place then you have the top
finisher in the feeder grants West
tournament at the Isle of Man tournament
which as of this year allows players to
qualify for the candidates tournament
but who does not qualify by one of the
above methods methods and is not Carlson
so that's one cow who won second place
now across the moon first place then you
have the top two finishers in the feeder
Grand Prix 2019 who do not qualify but
one of the above methods and of course
are not Magnus cross and Alexander
Grisha who won the feeder Grand Prix
altogether with 20 points and the
anypony who wanted who won second place
with 19 points then you have highest
average rating who does not qualify by
one of the above methods and is not
Carlson and that is uneasy Geary's know
a lot of you say that yes Maxine for
sherrilyn grub is higher rated than
onigiri but here it's it's the average
rating over the course of I believe 12
months so that's why Giri gets the spot
in the candidates not Maxine for Sheila
graph and a wild card chosen by ID
organizer subject to a eligibility
criteria is kiddo Alex & Co so yeah
there you have it
those are those are the eight players
that will be playing in the in the
candidates turn in 2020 to see who will
challenge Magnus calls and for the title
and out of these eight players if you if
you if we can leave them up for a bit
longer
who do you think has the well that's
basically a two-part question who do you
think has the biggest chance to win the
candidates tournament who is the you
know the best tournament player here and
and not related to that or it could be
related
who has the biggest chance to beat
Carlsen that's those are the questions
or if you want it can also be one
question so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it you know the the photos
the
a bit more talk about the candidates
tournament I would like to thank Daniel
drayage Trent was here John Roberts John
Hanselman and Benedict Friedel for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing well we we have to cover the
some places just a bit more to see how
truck is doing we're gonna check up on
your wonderful suggestions as always and
before we start the next big saga which
is the Paul Morphy saga we still have
the world blitz and rapid championship
from from Christmas to New Year's so
basically we are starting in the Morphy
saga in early January so that's pretty
much it thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day